have you heard about this government
shutdown yeah they are shut down I think
we're in day ten right now and you know
sure the NIH is closed so the kids can't
get cancer trials the world war two
memorial is closed so veterans can't
even check that our parks are closed
800,000 people are furloughed John death
benefits for servicemen killed in the
line of duty the twenty thousand dollars
they get to pay for their funeral and
help the family with costs yeah not
being issued not being issued all kinds
of craziness of course though Congress
there they're still getting paid even
though they're the ones that got us into
this because you know they really
deserve that but not only are they
getting paid their gym Congress is
exclusive gym that's also considered
essential and it's staying open what do
they have in their gym well they've got
a swimming pool basketball courts paddle
ball courts sauna steam room flat screen
TVs but we should note that the towel
service has been suspended I'm not
making that up should we expect any
better from these people they got us
into this mess they furlough all these
people all these people are getting
screwed by this it's harming the economy
but their gym was essential they do play
paddleball some know so off the badges a
paddleball horrible people it's like the
worst sport ever yeah is probable
parables elitist right paddle ball is
about to say do you use your hands but
I'm gonna catch you he's at that I
believe that paddle somebody odds right
there in the title little blue ball
right boss here talking about a group of
men who really have blue balls yeah
majan uh yeah I don't know this is one
of those stories that like is so right
who thinks they're gym should be open it
right i mean but it does tend to deflect
from the real issues you know it's just
one of the perks where you just get to
get mad at congress all over again but
the real things you should've asked them
for is you know through the
irresponsible governing a lack of
interest in government a hatred of
government which means of course if you
hate government when you shut down the
thing you hate they think it's good
right there that's why the not reading
these interviews today with some members
Republican members of Congress they're
like impervious to the criticism because
think the critics just don't get it
right so every time the critics say to
them well you know are you willing to
give up your pay or should the gym be
closed at well that's not what this is
about but it is kind of so is this just
their way of like extra sticking it to
us sort of like they were there already
sticking it to us and it's very clear
they're not doing the peak the work of
the people they're even doing work yeah
so it's sort of like yeah we're gonna
keep our gym open to because we are in
charge mhmmm yeah it might be a good
thing though like exercise is really
good for your heart and people are just
so stressed out like they might have a
heart attack so yeah at least are
working out yeah and legislating is all
about abs right that's right of course
you know the vice pres the United States
we are the bite the near vice president
I'd States last year was setting out
pictures with a baseball cap on
backwards leering at the guy remember I
believe he was on that he was doing the
p90x was he right so that I don't know
that that's have you seen that
commercial you get some straps all
that's what yeah so that you can do in
the privacy of all you don't even need a
gym for it that's the bullet but we
forget as these guys met especially
members the Tea Party but some other
members of Congress to a lot of these
guys so live in their office because
they think that they're in the people's
house and they're doing the people's
work and they don't want to be part of
the Washington establishment so they go
up briefly to Washington for the least
amount of time possible save money they
always say which is not really saving
the people's money they're just they're
saving their money right there electric
bill about you're not doing the people's
work you're just a cheap [ __ ]
yeah by the ethic perhaps you need to
realize that yet so these guys stay
there so they use the gym as their
shower as there are no showers and
members offices so like now though what
that essentially means is that these
guys who live in their offices are just
you know bang in their secretaries on
the people's futon you know see I was
going to say I feel like they're all in
the shower together okay that could be
that would be better well a lot of the
Republicans because you know they like
that I'll kind of stuff right now yeah
so if we can't expect better than we
just have to where do you think this
thing is going at this point because if
they just keep pulling all this stuff I
mean again I I totally agree with you
that it's all a distraction the world
war two memorial thing it's a
distraction from the real stuff but with
all this stuff for some reason this hits
people harder right when you hear about
the world war two memorial thing you
hear about the gym being
open it's more of a visceral feeling
because people are out of work and
they're not even given up a perk right
exact you know exactly um so it's bad I
would have closed it also have you
noticed you read the story the decision
to close the gym was made by the capital
architect yes whoo there you would
imagine that this guy's work was done
building was finished you'd be like hey
Larry great dome thanks for your work
but no they call Larry back and he's
like keep the gym oh yeah like what
house it is is it but he made it a
conjunction with the speaker's office
and they so they went along with it and
I'm gonna guess that Speaker Boehner he
reached those stories he sees
congressional job approval zat 9% he's
like well they can't go any lower yeah
i'll just keep the gym open yeah so I
eight people came out today the
Congress's approval is now at five
percent so it can go we can go slightly
lower is there any what other people
could there be besides Congress that
could be so bad at their job is there
anyone else if all bus drivers were this
bad we'd find another mode of
transportation wouldn't we I don't think
so you think we'd still take the baby
great I'll take the bus you're right
nobody's taking the bus out of joy and
it's always it's always been true uh is
that guys that they hate Congress but
they like their congressmen and so you
know it's always been like Congress is
the worst it's terrible my guy is good I
like him I'd like to begin I like him a
hundred times yeah he hates black people
eh games i'm pretty sure eh doozy can't
say that yeah i know i feel and so you
know you always send your guy back and
of course that just means 435 guys
basically go back doing a lot of nothing
hey guys we the report is brought to you
by cooper calm you can get up to
seventy-five percent off pet toys choose
all kinds of treats and more the link is
right down below click it and use code
RR for twenty percent off your first
purchase